[Music]
sad and shocking news from the music
world of this concerning rock icon Tom
Petty
the 66 year old legend was found
unconscious in full cardiac arrest
Sunday night at his Malibu home EMTs
responded and he was rushed to the UCLA
Santa Monica hospital where he was
reportedly put on life support Tom and
his band performed at the Hollywood Bowl
just last week telling the crowd it
would be his final tour earlier this
year he was honored by the Recording
Academy as MusiCares Person of the Year
I got into rock and roll at age ten I
was collecting records rock and roll
records not Rock this was rock and roll
he wrote the roll designates of Swing
[Music]
a Florida native Petty's first big hit
came in the late 70s as the frontman to
Tom Petty and the Heartbreakers he was
thrilled to perform at big events I'm
having a hard time putting it into words
through people it's there is something
very special in the air today in there a
man consumed with his craft he once told
us being on the road and recording took
up all of his time I don't really have
any hobbies you know I don't collect
things most of my time honestly is
consumed with music and trying to get
just trying to get you know 15 songs
done 15 songs written or an album
together it's very time-consuming
[Music]